probably in the
hey I would definitely grade them and
ask probably enough
I would say a c I would rate him an f
plus he hasn't handled anything I give
my nap on everything
inviting Biden has been
doing to me a poor job
well he doesn't know I don't care what
he says he doesn't know what is going on
just a few feet from here there's people
coming over they know they aren't going
to get caught and I I mean he says it's
going to be chaotic but and he says it
may go away but I don't think it's going
to I think it's just going to stay
chaotic since since it ends I think the
president is doing a wonderful job Henry
and Miss kamla uh they doing a wonderful
job
we were better with Trump you know
gasoline was cheaper the Border was
sealed I mean there was no you know
inflation this you know there's nothing
wrong with trying to help people that
are just looking for a better life but
you need to do it correctly you know
because these people's lives are falling
under your responsibility so you need to
do something about it if you're going to
let them in here for a better
opportunity like you say you do make
sure it's being done right and you know
they're not sleeping on the street like
you see them just here a couple blocks
away he just really has no grasp but the
idea of how serious it is
with everything he's doing right now
he's not going to do anything to support
it you know has he done anything since
he's been elected so no I don't believe
that he's gonna help a lot of things
that he's done or he said has not been
working
I think that can only come from Biden
and I don't think he's willing to I just
feel like they should really show what's
really happening don't go show little
perks and pieces where okay they're
getting food or they're being served or
they're getting
um sheltered no show the real people out
there on the street show what's really
happening to them you know all the news
and everyone's shows glimpses of oh
they're getting this help and that no no
they're not show the real story I don't
understand why you're saying all these
things and not helping and maybe you
don't understand so you don't visit
places enough to see what's actually
happening I think what has to happen and
this is just
it's just me it's Biden
and his group
I don't think they should ask there's
times when America needs to throw quote
its weight around this is one of them he
should tell
president of Mexico you and I are going
to get together on this date and we are
going to talk if you do not show up we
will take action on our own begins to
use he needs to use the power it has